[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be diving back into
hogwarts legacy content as over the past
few months we've been given snippet
after snippet of what's to come in the
upcoming game the planned release date
for the game is december 2022
but with how many times it's been
postponed so far it's really hard to say
if you aren't privy to hogwarts legacy
it's a new open world role-playing harry
potter themed game where we the player
embark on a journey to the wizarding
world
we're put in the driver's seat and we
can effectively interact with the
wizarding world however we want
the game takes place in the late 1800s
over 100 plus years before harry ever
steps foot through the doors of hogwarts
but that doesn't mean we aren't going to
come across familiar faces places and
the focus of this video creatures
today i'm going to be discussing 15
confirmed creatures that will appear in
some way in the new hogwarts legacy game
let's dive into it
1. dragons
dragons pop up in the harry potter films
quite a bit and are frequently referred
to as some of the most powerful
creatures in existence
dragons are giant winged fire-breathing
beasts that incite fear in the hearts of
even the bravest witches and wizards
they bear the potential to be extremely
destructive
and they are even classified as category
5x by the ministry of magic
this classification means that they are
known to kill witches wizards
and are either extremely difficult to or
impossible to domesticate
we see or hear mentions of dragons pop
up constantly throughout the books and
films and they are an integral part of
the series for these reasons it should
come as no surprise that dragons will
appear in hogwarts legacy from the
promotional material we've seen so far
it looks like our character will
encounter dragons in combat scenarios i
just wonder how many species of dragon
are included
2. trolls trolls which originally come
from norse mythology were giant humanoid
creatures of a men's size sometimes
growing as tall as 12 feet and weighing
up to one tonne
it's also worth mentioning that there
are several different subspecies of
troll including forest trolls mountain
trolls river trolls and the troll of
nadrage a troll subspecies with
disproportionately large hands
controls are incredibly dangerous
unpredictable violent and aggressive
creatures that have a taste for human
flesh
making them particularly terrifying
we see trolls in the trailer for
hogwarts legacy and i'm willing to bet
that we're going to need to use some
magic to confiscate those gigantic clubs
3. thestrals
ethestrel is a breed of winged horse
that possesses skeletal and reptilian
features resembling a sort of evil
pegasus
they have dragon-like heads pupilless
white eyes and vast black leathery wings
the ministry of magic considers
thestrals to be dangerous and they have
a bad rap as omens of misfortune because
they are only visible to those who have
seen death
we don't actually see thestrals until
the state of play that is but at one
point in the hogwarts legacy trailer we
see a flying carriage being magically
lifted into the air if you're any sort
of harry potter fan at all then you'll
know that thestrals are responsible
for mer people
mer people are sentient magical beasts
that live underwater and can be found
all over the world
they are certainly mysterious creatures
that we don't get to know very well in
the story only playing a relatively
small role
outside of hogwarts they reside in the
black lake and we only really see them
during the events of the second task of
the tri-wizard tournament where they
agreed to keep four people in an
enchanted sleep in their village for an
hour protecting them until they are
saved by their respective champion
provided that the lake near hogwarts is
featured in the trailer for hogwarts
legacy and that the lake is such an
important part of the school grounds i
suspect it's highly likely that we'll
encounter more people there
5. hippogriffs hippogriffs are magical
beasts that have the front legs wings
and head of a giant eagle and the body
behind legs and tail of a horse
one notable hippogriff in harry potter
was of course buckbeak who harry and
hermione helped save from execution in
1994
the game trailers feature hippogriffs on
a few occasions
so i'm positive that we're going to get
to experience them in game who knows
maybe we'll even run into them in the
care of magical creatures class 6.
acromantulas
acromanculars are basically giant
spiders if you remember the most notable
acromancular from the series is aragog
hagrid's old pet and the reason for his
expulsion from hogwarts acromantulas are
classified as a category 5x beast by the
ministry of magic and this is for good
reason it has been expressed that the
leg span of acromanculars can be as
large as 15 feet which makes them a bit
more intimidating than your average
house spider in the trailer we see a
hogwarts student fighting off an
acromantula and though we can say for
sure that this one wasn't aragog because
of the date the game is set in it
doesn't mean that there weren't others
living in the forbidden forest at the
time
seven dementors dementors are cloaked
creatures three meters tall with dark
grey scabby skin they are truly foul
creatures that represent unhappiness and
despair and they are frequently known to
be the guards of azkaban prison ensuring
that all the darkest witches and wizards
inside do not escape
dementors can strip you of your soul and
leave you just a shell of a person and
that kind of power can't be ignored
however their achilles heel is the
patronus charm as it is a positive light
force that represents everything that
they aren't as a result they are
repelled by its presence
this means that as long as the witch
wizard knows how to use a patronus charm
then they are safe from dementors
provided that one confirmed aspect of
hogwarts legacy is figuring out your
player's patronus i'm willing to bet
that we'll have to use them against
dementors at one point or another eight
in ferry the inferi or nefarious
singular is effectively a corpse that
has been reanimated by a dark wizard's
curse
according to pottermore the inferius
becomes a grizzly puppet used as an
expendable servant by a dark wizard
adding that an inferius can be spotted
by its white and cloudy eyes
harry and dumbledore are famously
attacked by inferi in the cave when
trying to retrieve one of voldemort's
horcruxes
and ferry are front and center in the
hogwarts legacy trailer so i can't wait
to see when we'll encounter them perhaps
we'll learn some sort of fire spell to
ward them off the homage to dumbledore
nine boggarts boggarts are essentially
manifestations of our deepest darkest
fears they are immortal shape-shifting
non-beings that transform into whatever
you fear most
no one knows what the pocket looks like
by itself because it will transform as
soon as you encounter it when buckets
aren't scaring people they can usually
be found to rustling around in confined
spaces all lurking around dark corners
boggarts are the perfect tool to keep
players on their toes and given that our
characters will enroll in defense
against the dark arts classes it's
inevitable that we're going to face a
boggart or two
i wonder if character customization will
allow us to choose our boggart
10. moon carves the moon calf was a shy
magical beast that only came out of its
burrow during a full moon
the moon calf had smooth pale gray skin
and four spindly legs that ended in
large flat webbed feet the moon calf
also had a very long neck and bulging
blue eyes that sat on the top of its
head
though the mooncarve was first brought
to our attention in fantastic beasts it
doesn't mean that the mooncalf's
presence is absent from harry potter or
hogwarts legacy for that matter we saw
moon carves on the very first trailers
for the game so you can bet we'll have a
chance to interact with them
11. giants giants are incredibly
powerful creatures they tend to live out
their lives in tribes completely
separate from the rest of the wizarding
community
they are smarter than trolls but
stupider than humans and their innate
bloodthirsty nature has typically
resulted in their own population control
giants have been known historically to
side with forces of evil rather than the
forces of good which means that if we're
lucky or unlucky i suppose we may just
get to fight off a giant or two in
hogwarts legacy
12. grab horn the grap horn is found in
mountainous european regions
large and greyish purple with the humped
back the grab horn has two very long
sharp horns walks on large four thumbed
feet and has an extremely aggressive
nature
we see the grap horn for the first time
in fantastic beasts and where to find
them as they don't make it on screen in
harry potter however fortunately for us
they appear to be all over the trailers
for hogwarts legacy i'm sure we'll deal
with them at one point or another
13. niffler
nifflers are magical beasts with a long
snout and a coat of black fluffy fur
they are commonly attracted to shiny
things which usually ends up getting
them into trouble you may remember newt
scamander's niffler was a rather
colourful personality
always getting up to no good
as it turns out in hogwarts legacy we
can be just like newt and have our own
niffler as a fluffy companion 14. fupa
the fupa was a magical african bird with
brightly coloured feathers which could
include orange pink lime green and
yellow listening to the fwoopers
high-pitched twittering song would drive
the listener insane
floopers aren't particularly well known
among harry potter fans so hopefully
their appearance in hogwarts legacy will
bring some awareness
15. centaurs
sentinels are beings taken from greek
mythology that possess the upper body of
a human in the lower body of a horse
the biggest distinction between centaurs
of mythology and centaurs in harry
potter is that harry potter centrals are
gifted in divination a magical
discipline that allows one to gather
insights into future events i've seen
centaurs all over the hogwarts legacy
footage and they're known to inhabit the
forbidden forest near hogwarts
so i'm positive we'll get to interact
with them whether that will be a
positive or negative interaction is
unclear
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel what other
hogwarts legacy videos do you want until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]
you